just bring you some breaking news on
covid19 and the alert level for covid is
to move
up from level four to level five
and a statement from the chief medical
officers
of the uk says following advice from the
joint
biosecurity center and in the light of
the most recent data
uh the four uk chief medical officers
and the nhs england medical director
recommend that the uk alert level
should move from uh level four
to level five let's go over to uh chief
political correspondent john craig who
joins me from westminster and john will
talk about
the prime minister and what he's going
to say in just a moment first of all
what's the significance of the alert
level being raised
what what level five means is that there
is
a there's judged to be a material risk
of health care services
being overwhelmed now in that statement
which confirms what we heard
uh from government sources earlier and i
mentioned an hour ago
there is now a statement uh from the uh
four
uh well five actually top medics uh
because there's the medical
director professor stephen powers as
well
as well as the chief medical officers
for england wales scotland and northern
ireland
and what appears to be happening now is
that we are we do seem to be moving
towards
what government ministers describe as a
four-nation approach
now uh in the last hour um
the uh chancellor of the dutch of
lancaster the cabinet office minister
michael gove
is also talking to uh arlene foster from
northern ireland nicola sturgeon from
scotland
and mark drakeford from wales the four
the three other the three uh first
ministers
uh of the other nations of the uk and uh
so we they are no doubt given that we've
already heard from
nicolas sturgeon earlier this afternoon
looks as though there is a move
certainly to achieve an or a four nation
approach tonight
on the question of a lockdown now wales
has already in lockdown
but we're all we are expecting that the
prime minister given that he's doing a
tv broadcast is going to announce a
lockdown later just
the statement we just had uh from the
medics
um it talks about advice from the joint
biosecurity center
it talks about the most recent data and
it talks about many parts of the health
systems in the four nations already
under immense pressure
very high rates of community
transmission substantial number
of uh coveted patients in hospitals and
in intensive care the statement says
cases are rising almost everywhere in
much of the country driven by the new
more transmissible variant and it says
we are not
confident that the nhs can handle a
further sustained rise in cases
and without further action there is a
material risk at the nhs in
several areas being overwhelmed over the
next
21 days um so
this obviously this statement comes two
hours before the prime minister's
um announcement on television and uh
number 10 when they announced that the
pm was to do this broadcast said
the spread of the new variants has read
has led to rapidly encasing case numbers
the prime minister is clear that further
steps must now be taken
to arrest this rise and to protect the
nhs and save
lives number 10 have also announced
that's confirmed by the speaker now
the house of commons will be recalled uh
on wednesday
sit at 11 30 statement from the pm
then a debate and vote on the measures
he's expected to announce
tonight